right if I already go in to pitch this
to someone and I was pitching it to the
two of you and you you both said we yeah
we don't like this and this and this so
would the open and workable response
from me ie the writer be great I can
come back and change it and could we
meet again with the friends I think you
have to do oh I'm sorry I mean I I would
not say that I would say what parts of
it didn't you like how would you like to
see it done because if they haven't
started the creative collaboration maybe
I can start it and so if they said well
I see it you know working much better
with a you know for a younger market and
I'd like to make these you know
mid-teens I'd say oh wow
I hadn't thought of it that way yeah
then you could debt it out it out or not
and the more I the more I can get you
involved
it's another terrific that we learned
from someone who's not in the book my
mentor who is in his 90s now but
sharpest attack and he he used to go in
and pitch tell them you know like
ongoing series and let's say but you owe
it by the way you're never gonna go to a
pilot meeting and have one pilot idea
and you're going to have somebody who's
more powerful than you or you're not
gonna get anywhere and you're gonna have
an agent who got you in the door unless
you're very lucky and I'm not sure
that's luck because you do need someone
looking out for you and protecting you
but the other thing that Peters always
said and this I think comes from a
science background is try to find out
what kinds of things that producer that
executive likes because if you go in and
pitch them westerns and they hate
westerns you're dead before you open
your mouth and that's maybe more for
movies I don't know but but just to
follow that idea if you have an idea for
Western and you know that they've made a
movie about an orphan and that really
touched their heart then you make sure
you have an orphan in your Western so
that you have a wave
or if you're like me you try to find out
what directors they admire and then find
a Western that director rate so for
example you know they like Martin Ritt
and they think Martin grid is the
greatest direct find that to find some
way in I guess is what we're saying and
the other the other thing is when they
say no move on don't argue
never get defensive never argue yeah
because you never want to go in with one
idea you're going what I do you're
asking unless you know obviously Aaron
Sorkin they're gonna come to Aaron I
mean there's a group of people they go
to pilot writing is almost in my
experience and I think it's the same as
it is now
he's almost never done by beginners they
want to go and it makes sense for them
right so if for example you pitch this
to a showrunner the only way you're
gonna get it made because you don't
talking about you in reality I'm talking
about you this person who hypothetically
puts this well you're gonna want
somebody who really knows what they're
doing or they won't bury you and they'll
make a bad deal with you whoever you
want someone who's got some chops and
some power
okay can we slip in a little bit of
pedantry for just a moment please
I don't know what it means like one of
my one of my favorite books is a book
called Thinking Fast and Slow it's
probably the smartest book I've read in
the last thirty years and it it
basically has the thesis that we have
two modes of thinking one where we get
very very rigorous and think very hard
and deep and the other is we think
intuitively and we make just about all
our decisions intuitively and what's
kind of interesting is that when we're
forced to think deeply which we don't
like to do because it's hard not only
are we thinking deeply but we're cranky
as we're doing it because it takes a lot
of our resources
and we're kind of skeptical as we're
doing it because we're forced to think
hard it's not in our regular way of
looking at things so when I'm pitching
something I'm thinking how can I keep
this so that they're intuitively
accepting everything I do I don't want
to put them in a place where they have
to go contrary so if I made some
controversial statement like you know
I've got this idea for a horror film
because we know that everybody secretly
always wants to do terrible things to
the people around them and somebody says
wait a minute I never want to do
terrible things to people around me the
minute I've got them at that point I've
lost them and I have to now find
instances and then they're going to
negate them over arguing instead of
finding something they're gonna agree
with right away and say you know most of
us like you know the easy way out when
things are really Pleasant and so we
make decisions like yeah I do that yeah
and then they're cruising along with me
and I've got a better chance the men and
I make them skeptical I've got a really
tough mountain to climb right that the
fellow who wrote this book Daniel
Kahneman is a Princeton psychologist
psychology professor who won the Nobel
Prize for economics it's a brilliant
book and I get no royalties from it
which hurts me no I'm so ready but I
praise it anyway think very slow it's a
great book but it just makes that really
good point that anything that you're
saying to somebody that seems like it's
within their realm of possibility that
they can accept without arguing you've
got an easier sell than if you're
stopping and saying well imagine this I
can't see that ever happening I just
want to come back to something you said
you said they'll bury you if you don't
can you do what I mean is that that what
what a lot of people don't want to see I
can't say all people who are experienced
is an inexperienced person especially a
young person in their early 20s coming
in and doing something that's above
their skill level they
know what you don't know because they've
been doing it even junior executives who
have a very short lifespan know that and
you always want to dial up you always
want to bring somebody with you who
knows more than you do and can believe
in you and help you those are also great
partnerships a 20 I'll give you an
example I also talked told Peter this
story this morning I had a student two
years ago I always I also told him that
I'm gonna look like the hero of this I'm
really not this is just my job I used to
hear oh no hostess like somebody
somebody has to make me the hero
somewhere I'm the villain everywhere
else you can say how are you sorry busy
today I think that the the best example
is I have a student two years ago who
was the best joke writer I twenty-one
years old and had done a lot of improv
but very young and she could work on
which is just what you want in a room
she could work on other people's scripts
and go you know this would be a great
joke and they would all come from
character and conflict and she said to
me in the beginning of the year because
it was a two semester of course she said
to me I'm gonna come out of here at 22
and I'm going right on to a television
series as a writer and I said to her I
hope not and and she got really mad at
me and I said hey you won't be ready be
they'll eat you alive and see they'll
resent you and so what you need to do is
pay your dues and then I found this or
she found this program data that second
city in Chicago had started a grad
program in Harold Ramis name in his
memory and she applied and she got in
and she just graduated in May I think or
she has maybe six months to go she's got
one more semester and she is like a
different kid because she took her time
you don't want to put your so I guess to
go back to your question is you don't
want to put yourself in a position where
you will get killed because they will
cave they have so many people to see and
they're looking for
things that they can sell it's still a
business no matter what it's on you know
even PBS oh you know British television
people yes it's so high-quality it is
but it's it's government supported on
the BBC so you know we'll see things
like the crown and things like that you
know or Downton Abbey that we can't you
know we have we rarely see here except
now we're seeing it on Netflix so I just
think it's always a good idea to dial up
don't try to be when you're young don't
go in and pretend to know that get
people to mentor you I think is the best
advice I've ever been given and it's the
best advice I could give is and take
your time because you want to be in it
for the long haul you don't want to have
like a gold strike and be done by the
time you're 25 this girl if she done
what she was had in her head she would
have been finished in 25 I think you
know how many how many if you look at
Orson Welles career his later career
even though he made some great movies he
didn't have the career he had at 26 it's
too young but he was a genius so that
doesn't really count
you